CLIFF LUNGARETTI: My
name is Cliff Lungaretti.
I will be your host today.
I'm part of the Talks
at Google program.
Thank you for joining us.
And Pat, let's
jump right into it.
We've seen the effect you've
had on the world in the past 12
months.
So, how did this all start?
How did you get diagnosed?
What was your first symptom?
PAT QUINN: I'm a young
man, so it was a long road
to a diagnosis for me.
I always start with-- it goes
back to the summer of 2013.
Actually, I'm sorry,
summer of 2011.
And we were playing in a
softball tournament all day.
I always like to say we won
the softball tournament.
It was good day.
And the next morning I
woke up and my left arm,
it was twitching.
So in my head, it
was a long day,
and there was a lot of fatigue.
So I just didn't think twice.
And a few weeks later, now my
left arm was still switching,
and I had a little
movement in my right.
So I figured, there's
a problem here.
Something's going on that
wasn't related to the softball
tournament.
So like any kid whose mother
was a nurse, I went to my mom.
And she freaks out.
So even when nothing
really was wrong,
the nurse instinct kicked in.
We went right so a
local neurologist,
who could only really
think, eh, it's a twitch.
It's benign fasciculation,
which is just
a big word for twitching.
And we went back two weeks
later because, hey, listen,
these twitches haven't stopped.
So you got to figure
something else out.
We got to do more tests.
And the way he saw it was,
I was way too young to have
a neurological disease.
But thankfully, he
wouldn't just let me go.
He decided, you know what,
this might be a bigger case
than I can handle, and
sent me to the Hospital
for Special Surgery
down here in Manhattan,
to see his-- the
doctor who taught him.
So by the time we got down
there, you're a little nervous,
but not-- not too much.
I mean, I'm lucky in one
regard-- my progression is
a little slow.
And because of that, my
diagnosis took a long time.
But that was also very tough,
because for a long time
you don't know what's
wrong with you.
And you're just going
to doctor appointment
after doctor appointment.
And we get these
big-time doctors.
They pretty much wring
you through the mill.
At first it's blood
tests-- negative.
You go for MRIs and CAT scans.
There's nothing popping up.
And then we have to go further.
So the next step is a spinal
tap, which I hope none of you
ever have to do, because
the headache the next day
was brutal.
But, again, negative.
Nothing happened.
And there's a million
other tests I went through.
It all led to eventually
trying a muscle neurobiopsy.
So I had to get a surgery.
I went under, and,
again, negative.
There nothing-- there's nothing
wrong with you, almost right?
But I was still getting weaker,
and nothing was confirmed yet.
So as this time passed-- it was
about a two-year time frame--
the last hope is
we were hoping it
was a case of multifocal
motor neuropathy, which
is a case of something
that mimics ALS,
but there is a treatment.
And the treatment is called
IVIG, and what you do is,
I went in the hospital
a week straight,
and they just pumped me full
of stuff for eight hours a day.
And before you know it,
you're just zonked out.
You're out cold.
Every day you wake up,
they pump you back.
And after that
week, I don't know
why, but there was some hope
that-- it didn't get worse,
so maybe we're going
to get lucky here.
But we went back into it one
last time, a biweekly IVIG,
and my symptoms were
still progressing.
So at that point, we were
leaning towards motor neuron
disease, ALS, Lou
Gehrig's disease,
or-- but I just don't
know why he-- we
didn't find out directly there.
We ended up going--
one day I went up
to Johns Hopkins in Baltimore.
Pretty much ran every
test that I had previously
done, except the spinal tap
and the surgery, thank God,
and that day they were able to
conclusively tell me that we
will diagnose you with ALS.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
And when was that?
PAT QUINN: That was March
13, 2013-- March 8, 2013.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
So almost two years
after the softball tournament?
PAT QUINN: Just about, yeah.
Almost.
I'm saying my buddy Pete Frates'
diagnosis was March 13, 2012.
I was March 8, 2013.
Too close.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
And you and Pete
are credited with starting
this legitimate worldwide
phenomenon.
So why ice?
[LAUGHTER]
PAT QUINN: It was hot.
No, I mean, we got lucky.
I really like to say that the
ice bucket challenge story,
it didn't start last summer.
It started way before that.
Because-- I know
everything in life
doesn't happen for a reason,
but I truly believe a lot does.
And you meet people
at certain times
in your life for a reason.
And after I was
diagnosed-- shortly
after-- I went on Google.
And I searched
young ALS patients,
and Peter Frates
is what popped up.
And I said, what the hell.
Let me give this guy a shout
and see if he responds.
What do I have to lose, right?
So I sent him an email.
We were on our way up, me
and my wife-- girlfriend
at the time-- we were
on our way to Boston
anyway, so I sent him an email
because she kept pushing me to.
Thank you, wherever you are.
And he answered.
So after our trip to Boston,
we went to-- I don't know Mass.
that well, but another town.
We got to meet Pat--
Pete-- in a restaurant,
and we just hit it off.
And he was really good
to me, really supportive,
and was all about helping me.
And that meant a lot.
I needed that
support at the time,
because I knew I
wanted to be proactive.
I'm young.
I'm energetic.
I like to be out
there, and like I
said before, my
progression is pretty slow,
so I feel I'll have
a long fight where
I can be a voice for
patients that progression
is a lot more rapid.
Because with ALS,
people are usually
in wheelchairs by now in my
case, or lost their voice.
I mean, my voice
is a little weaker,
but I'm still here
talking, so I'm
very lucky in the
whole scheme of ALS.
And that day he was
pretty much an open book.
He just said, ask me
what you want to know.
This thing isn't
easy, so ask now.
And let's get this thing going.
Let's create awareness.
And I think ever since then,
we-- me and my wife, my family,
friends-- we started Quinn for
the Win, a small organization
in Yonkers.
And we are doing
prototypical stuff
like three-on-three basketball
tournaments, golf outings.
I'm sure you can tell I'm Irish.
We went to bars and we had Irish
music, and people get fired up
and donate more.
I'm telling you, it's true.
[LAUGHTER]
But-- so we did that
a bunch of times.
And the awareness was--
we were out there.
I was on the news a bunch
locally in New York,
for my area, but it's just--
it wasn't good enough.
So we kept going.
We kept going, and thank
God a golfer in Florida
sent up an ice bucket over his
head and said, this is for ALS.
And the connection is, I
was linked to their network.
So I picked up on it right after
they started getting it going.
And like I said, you meet
people and you're connected
to people, all for a reason.
Not everything, but a lot.
And I feel the challenge
happened a town over from me
because I was meant to pick this
thing up and build it and get
the momentum going.
And because I had
made acquaintances,
now friends, and now even more
now, good friends, with Pete,
we have mutual friends.
So they have BC grads that
have come down and worked
in Manhattan.
A friend of mine, a
good friend of his,
Tim Holden-- after
Quinn for the Win
got Yonkers involved
and a lot more
places getting the
bucket challenge going--
this friend of mine,
good friend of his-- I
said that twice--
[LAUGHTER] Tim Holden--
thank you buddy-- put a
Quinn for the Win shirt on,
and BC shorts.
And that was it.
It connected New
York to Boston, and--
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Which
is all you really need.
[LAUGHTER]
PAT QUINN: --that was it.
New York was getting big.
Boston got incredibly
big super fast.
And because of Pete's
BC connections--
he played baseball--
athletes started doing it.
Once the pro athletes
got involved--
I think it was Matt Ryan,
Julian Edelman-- Boston
guys-- I can't hate them.
I like them now because
of what they did.
[LAUGHTER]
But they-- they got more
people involved with names
that people recognized.
So athletes were doing it.
Before you knew it,
actors, actresses,
people that were in the
media that could really
create that awareness we were
looking for were building.
And every day you would
see numbers increasing.
The new-- you would wake up
and say, who did it yesterday?
Who did it last night?
And it just kept getting
bigger and bigger and bigger,
and the numbers-- they
speak for themselves now.
I mean--
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Out
of everyone that did it,
who are you most like, oh
my God, that guy did this?
PAT QUINN: I get
that a lot, and--
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Is
there anybody that you
were just like, oh, man?
PAT QUINN: --I wish I
had a better answer.
I know a lot of people like
Bill Gates, 'cause he's huge,
and I think-- I'm not
a big LeBron James fan,
but he's one of the best
athletes in the world.
He did it.
Leonardo DiCaprio is
as big of an actor.
He did it.
I can't think of someone
who didn't do it, so--
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
Show of hands, anybody
here not do the ice
bucket challenge in 2014?
We got the whole
room, so-- [LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PAT QUINN: Yeah. [LAUGHTER] And
it's not worth getting picky,
because every challenge,
no matter how big or small,
was doing what we
originally set out to do,
which was create awareness,
and the money coming in
was just completely unexpected.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Well,
that was the thing
that-- I know when
it first started,
there was a lot of backlash
on the internet, of,
oh, people are putting
ice on their head,
but who's actually
donating money?
But actually, fundraising
spiked last August
during this entire process.
PAT QUINN: Incredibly.
I mean, the grand total
is $220 million globally,
which ALS has never seen before.
I mean, their budget
grew by leaps and bounds.
And because of what
happened last year,
there's a lot more
research going on.
There's a lot more
patient services.
I know of a precision
medicine program in Boston
that went from a
handful of patients
allowed to be involved to
over 100, approaching 300 now.
The value of what happened
will never be matched.
It was something that
started-- the New York Genome
Center, right down
the block, got
a grant that opened up
more genetic study for ALS,
which people feel could be
where a breakthrough comes.
And there's more and more stuff.
I don't want to get too
technical, 'cause I'm not,
but the science is there now.
There's doctors that see the
value and the money coming in
and want to help now.
So the brightest minds
need to be working
on this, because ALS
is very difficult.
It's a disease that is so
different in every individual
that it's not like
other diseases,
where you just focus
in on one thing.
Just for example, my progression
is a little slower than others.
I'm walking.
There's people that
die in the time frame
I've been diagnosed with ALS.
So it's very difficult,
and I understand
that because there hasn't been
a breakthrough in-- Lou Gehrig
gave his farewell speech from
baseball over 75 years ago.
It's his birthday,
actually, today.
Happy birthday, Lou.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: I was going
to say it's his birthday, yeah.
PAT QUINN: And last time I
spoke with Ryan from Google,
it was Lou Gehrig's last game.
And today it was Lou
Gehrig's birthday,
so I thought there was meaning
in that, but-- where were we?
[LAUGHTER]
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Where were we?
Actually, one of things
I wanted to bring up
is basically, 2015,
where do you go here?
You were honored
at the Webbies--
PAT QUINN: That was cool.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: --with a
special achievement award
by one Dave Grohl, I believe.
And you had, of
course, five words.
So if you could tell everyone
your five-word speech?
PAT QUINN: Every
August until a cure.
And we're really
riding that right now,
because like I stated
before, the ice bucket
challenge was a great
start to a lot of stuff.
By no means is there a
treatment or a cure yet.
So I know the public
perception may be,
what do they need
more money for?
I mean, they've raised
$155 million in the US,
220 globally.
It's because nothing's
happened yet.
Things are just getting started.
Like I said, the
research is flowing out.
It was a great building
block, but nothing's ending.
I get weaker every day.
Every couple months I can notice
something pretty significant.
My arms are very weak right now.
So we-- I'm here talking because
I want more people to know.
The awareness has to
continue, because there
will be a breakthrough.
It'll happen eventually,
whether in my lifetime or not.
We're going to fight
for it every day.
And the best way to do that
is the ice bucket challenge,
we learned last summer.
And regardless of the
magnitude this year,
it has to happen again because
of what happened last year.
No matter how big
or small, it will
be significant to
the ALS community,
because more money will
come in than any other time
the rest of the year.
So although I feel it
will be very successful,
and I have goals in my head
of bigger than last year--
which people may think
crazy-- but go big or go home.
You gotta think big
to make a difference.
And--
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
So every August
we can expect to throw
ice on our heads again.
PAT QUINN: Until we figure
something out, every August.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: I know
some co-workers here
who were hoping to see me
get doused with ice today.
We're going to wait till August.
[LAUGHTER]
It's still too early.
PAT QUINN: I got you
off the hook today.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Thank you.
If anyone would like
to ask any questions,
we have two microphones
in the aisles.
I'll call on you if
you want to come up.
No pressure, but they
are there if you want
to talk to Pat about anything.
But yeah.
So, the Webbies, and
then that led to August--
and this is me trying to find
my own train of thought here.
PAT QUINN: I'm sorry.
I mean, what happened since
last summer has been nuts.
I mean, I've grown to
enjoy being in front
of people talking about this.
When I was in school, I didn't
want to get called on anything.
So the way I always
explain it is,
I have a real passion
for what I'm doing now.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Well, May was
ALS Awareness Month, correct,
so you have talked all
over the place lately.
PAT QUINN: Yeah, yeah.
I did a-- I'm pumping
myself here, but whatever--
I did a satellite media tour--
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
The floor is yours.
PAT QUINN: --and I sat in front
of a camera for five hours
and just did local
news broadcast
after local news broadcast,
radio, for the whole morning.
And the next day, I
was getting feedback
from all over the country
of how interested they
were in my story
and how they want
to know what we're doing next.
And that's why I'm here.
You just keep building
on the momentum
we created last summer.
And something's going to happen.
Things change, and we're
trying to make that change now.
And seriously, I mean,
there's a lot of people here.
Don't hesitate to ask.
I know someone has
to break the ice--
I didn't mean that because I--
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Yeah, you did.
[LAUGHTER]
PAT QUINN: But I mean,
I have a unique story.
I know I'm young
for what I have,
so if there's something in
your head, please do ask.
I'm very open.
I just-- I'm confident
in what's going on,
so don't feel weird
asking anything.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Brian?
AUDIENCE: I don't know if I'm
allowed to ask first, but--
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Sure.
AUDIENCE: When you said that
Bill Gates did the ice bucket
challenge, I was thinking
about this year-- even if you
kind of get millions of people
to do the ice bucket challenge,
if you could get more Bill
Gates and Larry Pages and Mark
Zuckerbergs who would, even if
they don't do the challenge,
they also have very,
very deep pockets.
Because we see-- and
how do we get more Bill
Gates to get involved with ALS?
And I don't know
if that's something
that you and your team
have thought about?
And it's not only
that, but I also think,
even if it's not resources, you
think of all these conditions
that-- things like hepatitis
C, which used to-- now
there's treatment
that actually can
solve that in 12 weeks-- and
all these other conditions
that are out there.
Then if we can just get enough
resources, enough money or even
brainpower-- there's some very
smart people in this room,
and who knows what they
can be doing to help.
So have you thought about that?
Outside of just simply
getting a lot of people
to do the ice bucket challenge,
how can we get some big hitters
like the Bill Gates involved?
PAT QUINN: We always
think about that,
'cause you want to
think from the top down,
but I feel the more awareness
you create from any level
will draw attention
from the biggest names.
It did last year, and engaging
them early on this year
is a priority.
I know once we start
kicking things off,
people will start
to recognize it
as long as we get the
media going again.
And I mean, Bill Gates put
some real thought into his.
He created a whole device
that poured the ice bucket.
Hopefully you're thinking
right now, Bill, because we
need another one like that.
But that's a great question.
I mean, in my head, in my
network, we're out there now.
And we're connecting
with everyone that will.
And as long as they're are
open to doing it again,
we're going to be
there for them.
But we're just
going to build on it
as much as we can, and
then go from there.
And like you said, there's
breakthroughs in diseases
all the time.
And with ALS, there hasn't
been in a long time.
It's an orphan disease.
They say approximately
30,000 people in the US
have it any given
time, but there's
real facts that keep
patients' voices down.
One in particular that will
really grab your attention
is, every 90 minutes
there's a patient diagnosed,
but every 90 minutes
another patient dies of ALS.
Thanks, Jason.
But it's a disease
that takes people
as quickly as they
diagnose them,
so the voices don't last long.
I think I mentioned earlier
that with the-- I don't
like to say my
progression is slower,
because my arms are weak.
I can't use them.
And I don't think
it's fair to say
someone has fast or slow
progression, kind of.
The disease stinks regardless.
But I'm here talking after
two years, and I feel,
not obligated, but it's my
job to be here for others that
can't.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Hey Pat, thanks so
much for being with us today.
Your story's beyond
inspirational.
I actually have three questions.
I hope that's OK.
PAT QUINN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm going to
bundle them all together
and just fire them away.
Answer them in whatever
order you prefer.
First, you mentioned this golfer
is actually the first one who
poured it over his head.
I'm curious if you know what
catalyzed him to do something
really bizarre that
ended up trickling
into a worldwide phenomenon.
Number two is, every
August until a cure.
Is there anything you
want to see different
in 2015 that did not happen
last year-- either a new spin
on the challenge, or a
new goal, or new, just,
ideas that would be
different that last year?
And lastly, have you considered
celebrity endorsements
such as Vanilla Ice,
Ice Cube or Ice-T?
[LAUGHTER]
Just throwing that out there.
PAT QUINN: I'll start
with the last one.
If you guys know any way of
getting in touch with them,
I'd love that.
[LAUGHTER]
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
Well, now we know
the three people to challenge.
PAT QUINN: Yeah, yeah.
The first one, the
guy, Chris-- the reason
why he did it was his
cousin's husband had ALS.
And he sent it up to
New York, in Pelham,
which is right next door to
where I'm from in Yonkers,
and like I said, we just--
everything connected
so perfectly that
it's almost eerie.
Like, why-- the way
it all happened,
it was meant to happen.
And it's really
gonna be the start
of the end of this disease.
Because of what
happened last summer,
more money has come in to
support our cause than ever.
And there's stuff happening now.
People have hope
in the community.
Like I said, I'm
young I'm out there.
I like to have fun.
So I'm proactive.
I don't mind telling my story.
I mean, the first couple
weeks after diagnosis,
where do you go, what do you
do, how do you tell people?
You cry a lot.
It's not easy.
But you break through
that mold, then
you come out a stronger person.
And ever since then,
I've been out there,
put my voice out there,
let people see me.
Because people need
to know it's a disease
that doesn't discriminate.
I'm a young man.
Most people think it's an
old person's disease, which
is a misconception.
Anybody can get this disease.
There's more and more
patients since the ice bucket
challenge that are willing to
talk about their condition.
It's not as rare, so they're
open to going out and building
support.
And not only does that
help their local community
and their comfort level, but
it builds more awareness.
And I always to say, the
awareness leads to the funding,
and the funding leads
to the research.
Without the three,
nothing happens.
AUDIENCE: Thanks a lot.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Thank you.
Yes sir.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
Very inspirational.
I'm picturing pouring
ice on my head in August.
It's a great idea.
One thing I'm
thinking is, as I pass
that out through my network,
people are gonna say,
why again?
Is there a site that I could
link to in my social media
pages that says,
this $220 million
that we raised last August
did these wonderful things.
That's just the
tip of the iceberg.
Here's where we're
going now, right?
PAT QUINN: The ice
references don't get old.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Right?
[LAUGHTER] That just came out.
[LAUGHTER] So then-- that
sums it up quickly to say,
here it is.
Here's what we accomplished.
Here's where we're going.
Does that exist?
PAT QUINN: I believe
there's a few infographics.
The ALS Association
has one on their site.
I think ALSTDI has
one on theirs as well.
I mean, I could
explain a little.
I read a lot about it.
The ice bucket challenge
through the association
has started five new
research programs.
One is Project Mind,
which is genetics-based.
They funded the New
York Genome Center,
which is also genetic-based, and
involved in genome sequencing.
What else was there?
The genome center,
Project Mind-- I lied.
I guess I didn't
know as much as I--
but they started five new ones.
I believe there's infographics.
In regards to the next--
this coming August,
when we hope to make it as big
as we can again-- recently,
because of the ice
bucket challenge,
for the first time ever
in the ALS community,
there was Collaboration
for a Cure.
ALS organizations--
a lot of nonprofits,
they usually work on their
own, for their own cause,
and their own path.
And I get that.
But we need teamwork
to beat this thing.
It's not easy.
So since the ice
bucket challenge,
we had the Collaboration for
a Cure, which brought the 18
major ALS
organizations together,
and we're all going to work
on the ice bucket challenge
together.
I'm pretty involved
with all the planning,
and I liked-- I guess I'm
giving the patient perspective,
keeping them from trying
to make it too corporate,
because everyone knows
last year was very organic
and had a real feel
for the patient.
And the vibe of the whole
ice bucket challenge
was so organic that people
were inspired by it.
If you have companies
doing it first,
it would just throw it off.
So I'm really excited
to be involved
and to hopefully keep
this thing going.
But-- I rambled
there-- but they're
gonna have a microsite
that will have a link.
Hopefully most people
will be able to use that.
We'll have all the organizations
listed with what they do,
and then you could
decide specifically
where your donation can go.
AUDIENCE: Perfect, thank you.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: So
actually-- so the ice bucket
challenge last
year, you mentioned
Bill Gates made a machine
which led to a lot of people
kind of get inspired to make
almost art projects out of it.
So even Dave Grohl, he
did the "Carrie" video--
PAT QUINN: Yeah, yeah.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI:
--which was really fun.
Is there any of
those that you really
enjoyed-- that you were really
impressed that someone did
that much trouble to be, like,
wow, they made an art piece out
of raising awareness for ALS?
PAT QUINN: I mean, it started
really simple with the bucket,
and then people
slowly-- by week four,
it was-- people were
using bulldozers,
and I had a friend
jump in the bucket,
which was completely ridiculous.
I mean, it just kept
getting bigger and bigger.
I forget the hockey
player's name,
but he had the bucket
dropped from a helicopter.
I mean, it probably
cost him more
to do it than the donation,
but it created awareness.
And I mean, either
way you're helping us,
and we appreciate that.
But I missed the last
gentleman's second question,
'cause it just clicked that
our goal is, if you did it
last year, do it different.
Try and mix it up a little bit.
Do a little better.
Do a little bigger.
And we found out in the
data that a lot of people
didn't do it.
So we're gonna try
and engage people
that didn't do it to
be challenged by me,
be challenged by Pete,
be challenged by someone
in your community that has ALS.
And just go out
and do it for them.
I mean, you have
nothing to lose,
but support of a person
that's struggling,
and a cause that so
desperately needs your support.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Pete, I
hope you'll challenge me.
I'm sorry, Pat, I hope
you'll challenge me.
PAT QUINN: I'll come down
here and do it with you.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: All right.
We'll have you on
back in August.
AUDIENCE: Hey Pat,
thanks for being here.
So you talk a lot about being
a voice of the ALS community
and for raising
awareness about ALS.
How much time and
energy do you put
into connecting with other
patients, ALS patients,
one on one, kind of
like Pete provided
that support to you initially?
Can you just kind
of talk about that?
PAT QUINN: Yeah.
I appreciate that question
because what he did for me,
I want to do for anyone who,
pretty much, seeks it out.
I've met with a lot of
patients-- old, young, local,
on Facebook.
People message me
all the time, and I
hope I got back to most of you.
I'm-- I'm out there.
And I feel, like I
mentioned before, I
have a progression
that's gonna allow
me to be vocal for a long time,
and hopefully inspire a lot
of people to get out there.
Not just patients, but family,
friends-- and keep this thing
going.
The momentum created last
summer can't be something
that we ignore.
We have to keep
building on it, and
by inspiring other
patients-- or maybe not.
Just telling them I'm there.
Give me a message.
Shoot me a message.
I'll tell you how I'm feeling,
you tell me how you're feeling.
How can I help you?
I could tell you what
my experience is,
and hopefully we can
relate a little bit,
because this is an
orphan disease which not
many-- many people get here.
So you're not gonna just
walk down the street
and find someone to talk about.
You have to go out and look
for them, like I did with Pete,
and many people have done
for me, which I appreciate.
And it's amazing what the
internet and Facebook and stuff
can do, because we
really got out there.
We connected with
a lot of people.
And it's just a
very tough disease.
There's no treatment.
There's no cure.
There's no reason--
they can't tell me
why I got it, which is crazy.
At least tell me
what I did, you know?
But that also hurts.
[INAUDIBLE] you really
can't give much.
You give a recommendation.
Like, I go to physical
therapy once a week.
I go to PT, OT, trainers,
get stretched out,
because I can't move my arms.
I need someone to help me with
that or they'll get locked up.
So there's small
vitamin regimens
I could recommend
that I do often.
I was a pretty
militant early on,
but my swallowing has got
a little more difficult,
so some pills are
enormous and just
not worth dealing with anymore.
But like I said, there's
very little options,
so I think the
patient-to-patient connection
is where the value is.
Not so much advice.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Well
Pat, I-- one more?
AUDIENCE: Thanks for being here.
If you want to help,
how can we help you,
besides doing the
ice bucket challenge?
PAT QUINN: Me?
Or-- no, I'm just kidding.
There's many ways.
The ALS Association does walks.
There's a corn toss event for
TDI, which is a research place.
If you go on Google--
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Thank you.
PAT QUINN: --there's
stuff out there.
I mean, you could look
into your local community.
An ALS patient needs your help.
I'm very lucky.
I got married after diagnosis.
I had a great wife.
My dad's here.
My mom's been great.
I have family and friends
like most patients don't.
So I'm lucky in that regard.
But there's older
people that get
this disease that have nothing.
I mean, even a conversation
would probably help their day.
There's little
things on that level.
Or running fundraisers
to advance research.
If you look into that, there's
Project ALS in Manhattan
here that I'm sure would
love to hear from you.
If I got your email I
could probably bombard you
with a bunch of stuff.
But it's out there.
You can find it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Thank you.
All right, Pat.
I am a big believer in
the mantra that we spend
the first half of our life
trying to be successful
and the second half
trying to be significant.
You're doing both.
It's an honor to have you here.
Would you like to leave
us with anything else?
PAT QUINN: Sure.
What I have isn't easy.
It gets tougher and
tougher as the road goes.
But I like to think
everyone faces adversity
at some point or
another in their life,
and the way you face that
challenge, or that adversity,
is how you'll be remembered.
And it'll create
a legacy in a way.
And I'm trying to do that
now by inspiring people
and fighting every day.
And like I said, you will
face adversity if you haven't.
Life ain't easy.
It's difficult. But
as another inspiration
of mine, Steve Gleason, would
say, awesome ain't easy.
And we're going to keep
being awesome until we
figure this thing out.
CLIFF LUNGARETTI: Pat, thank you
for being here with us today.
[APPLAUSE]